[Music]
poverty in the countryside and Western
affluence
in the capital Yerevan Armenia is a
country marked by stark contrasts
awareness and knowledge are key until
1991 Armenia was a part of the former
Soviet Union after the collapse of
communism the country fell into an
economic crisis and still hasn't fully
recovered small and mid-sized companies
struggle so Environmental Protection has
to yield profits 2014 our new wastewater
recycling unit has saved us over 100
thousand euros companies here have
rarely put much thought into
environmentally-friendly production but
things are starting to change
vehicle money that just cause my fingers
if we reorganize our production
successfully then it also makes good
business sense Armenia's economy is
largely dominated by agriculture cereals
fruit and vegetables are the main crops
like here at the foot of Mount Ararat
with some 3,000 hours of sunshine a year
peaches apricots and plums grow in
abundance
this fruit farmer turns his harvests
into dried fruit he switched to organic
production and no longer uses chemical
fertilizers and pesticides a local
environmental NGO helped him make the
switch financial support comes from the
international climate initiative the
organization advises companies about
sustainable practices the fruit farmers
ovens are now solar-powered and have
more efficient ventilation the fruit
drying process is now five times faster
saving energy and cost production in
Armenia and our region isn't big enough
to compete with neighboring countries
such as Iran or Turkey since Armenia is
a small country
it needs competitive products fruits and
dried fruits are among those products
the dried fruit now has an EU organic
certification and these days also sells
in France without any doubt it's also
about the person when he starts
something he want to finalize it and
finish it with a good result many
Armenian businesses would like to get
their foot in the door of European
markets but before that can happen they
need to improve production standards and
boost their environmental credentials
industry accounts for just 25 percent of
Armenia's GDP today new Najera Union is
visiting battery factory
the outskirts of Yerevan byproducts of
the production process sulfuric acid and
lead used to end up in the factories
wastewater but the company has now found
a cleaner solution not many people are
necessarily analyzing or viewing the
process because business person looks on
his benefits how he runs the business
and it's not necessarily that he knows
all the details on the impact on
environment the car battery is cooled
before they're charged the factory now
uses technology that cleans the cooling
water after the charging process so it
can be recycled along with the rest of
the wastewater
some two million euros were invested in
the new facility
we stopped the bicyclist Revati water
ended up in the sewage system so we
needed a closed system the water didn't
leave the factory this way we save huge
amounts of water second which also makes
economic sense the led is partly
recycled and waste led re melted so
there's a saving of over 500 euros of
material per ton it's a more efficient
use of resources meanwhile in this
bakery leftover pastry is no longer
simply thrown away it's turned into
biscuits
sometimes the solutions are simple any
bread that isn't sold is turned into
breadcrumbs
another of the ngos ideas and the
breadcrumbs have proved a best-seller
[Music]
you
you